welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and today I want to talk
about Starship Troopers why the 1997
Classics one of my favorite sci-fi films
of all time but the more I look into it
the more I start to see now on the
surface the film features Johnny Rico
leading his Squad to Glory against the
big bad bugs but what if what if I told
you the main Call to Arms was secretly a
false flag caused by Humanity what do
you mean what do you what do you mean
what do you mean now I'm talking about
is the destruction of Buenos Aries which
acts as a way to get people to enlist
you probably think I'm mental right well
let's put on our tin file hats and
hopefully by the end of this I manag to
convince you if you agree then please
hit the thumbs up and if you don't then
the dislikes there but really your
need to wake up and subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every week
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let us dive into Starship
Troopers
okay so to set the stage we see Johnny
Rico getting kicked out the military
this is due to an accidental death that
ends up happening under his command
video calling his parents they happy
coming back but something strange then
happens as the call ends we love you
son no what's that moments later we find
out an asteroids hit the planet and
wiped out Johnny's home leaving nothing
but Ash immediately you want to join in
the fight and head out to stamp down the
bugs the only good bug is a dead Bud we
find out after that people are enlisting
on mass and in many ways it reflects
real life the official stats in the
aftermath of Pearl Harbor say that
130,000 Americans joined the military
within 30 days of it less than a year
later there were 50 million Americans
working for the war effort showing how
much this drove up registration there
were even rumors at the time that the
president knew about it beforehand and
even let it happen as it could act as a
way to get people to enlist now that's
that's a crazy conspiracy theory yeah
but the the one I've got for you today I
swear it's true now that is that the
entire bug attack was orchestrated by
the humans in order to get people to
enlist this would help to secure
military funding and mean the Federation
stays operational now what the film does
is that it paints out a society that's
wholly ried on there being an enemy the
entirety of the civilization that we see
is built off the back of military rule
and whether it's in the classroom the
constant propaganda ads running or how
you get citizenship it's all building
off the back of being in the military at
this we see people protesting though and
you could argue there are certain people
who don't want this to be some people
might even question if the war's worth
it cuz all we get is this desolate
planet however those in charge need to
keep things moving and in order to do
this we need to have an enemy if there
isn't a war then their society could
collapse and who knows what would happen
to the government but from what we see
humans have stuff fighting amongst
themselves and even the criminals are
executed quickly we meet a prisoner
who'd been caught for murder and within
24 hours he was then tried and executed
this shows how unquestioned the
government are and how quickly they can
push things through again people might
start to question things like is that
trial Fair unless they need something
that puts the military at the top
getting us all United under their direct
rule that's something this attack does
which makes me think there's something
else going on this is of course
something that Watchman also touched
upon with a false flag attack happening
at the end of that that also brought us
together and though might sound like a
crazy Theory let us look at the science
behind it so at two points in the movie
we see the distance between Earth and
kenthu which is shown to us in
propaganda news reports the first one of
these happens at the beginning when we
get the news report explaining the bug
media now I'm not somewhat of a
scientist myself but these are clearly
billions or even trillions of light
years away the second report comes right
after the asteroid strike which shows a
path that traveled from kendu now as we
know the planets in the solar system
they're const conly moving and spinning
through space where we are now that
won't even be where we are in half a
second's time and we're constantly
moving at vast speed throughout the
cosmos thus in order for the bugs to hit
us they need to have Next Level math the
way it's explained to us is that meteors
over their Planet providing them with an
unlimited amount of ammo from the planet
a bug then fires up into space and
knocks one of these directly towards
Earth so let me get this straight right
they they do that and then the media
travels Across the Universe and gets a
bullseye on us in order to pull this off
you'd not only have to know where you
were in space but then also know where
the Earth was you then have to work out
where it would be in a trillion light
years time and also what exact angle to
hit the meteor at this would need to be
worked out so that when you hit it it
travels on a straight path directly
towards us you see with that distance
that kind of distance mate even if you
get it wrong by a degree it's going to
miss us by trillions and trillions of
Miles let's pull that map back up and
draw a straight line between our planets
so you can can get an idea of exactly
what I mean now let's move that line by
just one degree so you can see how much
of a difference that it makes now this
is without even factoring in that all
these planets and systems are constantly
spinning at a rate that adds countless
extra variables also in order for the
bugs to be able to pull this off they'd
have to shoot the media aons and aons
and aons AG go love saying that and
they'd also have to know what the mass
of the rock was and also what speed to
hit it at to make sure it traveled to
the point we'd be at you'd also have to
be aware of how fast the planets move
and yet no way can the bugs do all that
from what we see they don't have any
technology and most likely wouldn't have
even known we existed back when they
needed a fire at the media it's also
clear that the official human stances
that bugs aren intelligent and this is H
home by this line brain bugs frankly I
find the idea of a bug that thinks
offensive so clearly Humanity thinks
that bugs are dumb and wouldn't be
capable of carrying this out again
there's just too many variables May and
this is made more complex by another
scene that happens with the crew of the
Roger young which we see piloted by
Captain kman kman ends up encountering
the media that later on ends up hitting
our planet the ship hits against it and
barely scrapes by but again this is
something that would make a change
course going back to the idea of angles
this would have caused it to ve off
course slightly meaning that the media
would have missed anyway so technically
technically the Roger young might have
been what caused it to hit Earth I'm not
buying it though I think it was always a
false flag and in the opening report
something else seems a foot in it we see
another rock heading towards the planet
and this is again about to hit Buenos
Aries however we're saved by this brand
new ship which the Federation now has
for planetary defense no doubt that cost
a bunch but because of the attack the
government's obviously now funded no
matter what they'll always have money
for Wars and this is of course something
that we've seen in real life now on top
of this look at the animation that they
knock out to showcase the attack I know
Kevin spoiler is he's got a he's got a
reputation for getting videos out
quickly but I don't even think we could
have got this report out seconds after
it happened it's detailed has a mix of
graphics and lots of footage of the
aftermath that would have happened just
mere minutes before how they would have
managed to get this compile it and put
it in a report you couldn't bloody do it
and it shows that they likely had all of
this to hand it's like when it's like
when they have footage from another
thing you know make the conspiracy
theories you've seen them and they say
one tragic event is using footage from
another a tragic event the report also
makes it clear that they didn't use
Wormhole technology and that the
asteroid traveled directly from kenthu
I've seen that often used as reason to
explain it but yeah I doubt the bugs
have any grasp or understanding of how
black holes and whm holes work and if
they'd even transport a media to the
right place to continue its Journey Also
let's dive into the ethics of Journalism
to talk about what's going on normally
when attacks happen like this in real
life we wait until there's one of two
things that is an investigation into who
carried it out which normally takes at
least several hours either that or a
group claims credit for it and comes
forth as the ones behind it there's no
way that Humanity would be able to say
that this was the bugs in such a short
space of time this is literally a minute
after Rico's phone call which isn't near
enough time to know if it's the case
even if they had that assumption you'd
still want to double check but nope
ready to blame them straight away now
I'm no bug sympathizer yeah but they
didn't own up to it either again
Humanity also thinks the bugs are stupid
so why would they immediately know that
it was them no they wouldn't you scumbag
no I think they were in on it and they
either let it happen or carried it out
themselves this is all to continue the
industrial military complex and gain
support for spending and enlistment in
the war telling people as an enemy
that's one thing but showing an enemy
can eradicate you it puts the fear of
God into you the only thing to do is
fight back and Humanity clearly wants
kendu with we know from the hints
towards colonization they clearly want
us to agree that that's the right thing
to do and I I hope this video has helped
to prove it I'm so glad you listened so
we now know the truth who's who's that
Quick Share the video expose the truth
the truth the truth is out there wake up
spoiler
Society